Hey it's Evan Carmichael and I'm here with
Diana Nightingale and what you're about to
watch is the official version of The
Strangest Secret so if you want to
support the Nightingale family this is the
version to watch and share Diana you want
to share something I do I want to tell you
to join the millions of people from around
the world who have listened to this recording
and it's changed their lives for the better
enjoy I'd like to tell you about The Strangest
Secret in the world world not long ago Albert
schwitzer the Great doctor and Nobel Prize
winner was being interviewed in London and
a reporter asked him doctor what's wrong with
men today the great doctor was silent a moment
and then he said men simply don't think and it's
about this that I want to talk with you we live
today in a golden age this is an era that man
has looked forward dreamed of and worked toward
for thousands of years but since it's here we
pretty well take it for granted we in America
are particularly fortunate to live in the richest
land that ever existed on the face of the earth a
land of abundant opportunity for everyone but
do you know what happens let's take a 100 men
who start even at the age of 25 do you have
any idea what will happen to those men by the
time they're 65 these 100 men who all start
even at the age of 25 believe they're going
to be successful if you asked any one of these
men if he wanted to be a success he'd tell you
that he did and you'd notice that he was eager
to life that there was a certain Sparkle to his
eye and erectness to his carriage and life seemed
like a pretty interesting adventure to him but by
the time there's 65 one will be rich four will be
financially independent five will still be working
54 will be broke now think a moment out of the 100
only five make the grade why do so many fail what
has happened to the sparkle that was there when
they were 25 what's become of the dream the hopes
the plans and why is there such a large disparity
between what these men intended to do and what
they actually accomplished when we say about 5%
achieve success we have to define success and
here's the definition success is the progressive
realization of a worthy ideal if a man is working
toward a predetermined goal and knows where he's
going that man is a success if he's not doing that
he's a failure success is the Progressive
realization of a worthy ideal R May the
distinguished psychiatrist wrote a wonderful book
called man search for himself and in this book he
says the opposite of courage in our society is not
cowardice it is Conformity and there you have the
trouble today it's Conformity people acting like
everyone else without knowing why without knowing
where they're going now think of it in America
right now there are over 14 million people 65
years of age and old over and about 13 million of
these 14 million are broke they're dependent on
someone else for life's Necessities now we learn
to read by the time we're seven we learn to make a
living by the time we're 25 usually by that time
we're not only making a living we're supporting
a family and yet by the time we're 65 we haven't
learned how to become financially independent in
the richest land that has ever been known why we
can form and the trouble is that we're acting like
the wrong percentage group the 95% who don't
succeed now why do these people conform well
they don't know really these people believe that
their lives are shaped by circumstances by things
that happen to them by exterior forces they're
outer-directed people a survey was made one time
that covered a lot of men working men and these
men were asked this question why do you work why
do you get up in the morning 19 out of 20 had
no idea if you ask them they'll say everyone
goes to work in the morning and that's the reason
they do it because everyone else is doing it now
let's get back to our definition of success who
succeeds the only man who succeeds is the man who
is progressively realizing a worthy ideal he's
the man who says I'm going to become this and
then begins to work toward that goal I'll tell
you who the successful people are a success is
the school teacher who's teaching school because
that's what she wanted to do the success is the
woman who's a wife and mother because she wanted
to become a wife and mother and is doing doing a
good job of it the success is the man who runs the
Corner Gas Station because that's what he wanted
to do the success is the successful salesman who
wants to become a top-notch Salesman and grow and
build with his organization a success is anyone
who is doing deliberately a predetermined job
because that's what he decided to do deliberately
but only one out of 20 does that that's why today
there isn't really any competition unless we make
it for ourselves instead of competing all we have
to do is create now for 20 years I looked for the
key which would determine what would happen to a
human being was there a key I wanted to know which
would make the future a promise that we could
foretell to a large extent was there a key that
would guarantee a person's becoming successful if
he only knew about it and knew how to use it well
there is such a key and I found it have you ever
wondered why so many men work so hard and honestly
without ever achieving anything in particular and
others don't seem to work hard and yet seem to get
everything they have the Magic Touch you've heard
them say that about someone everything he touches
turns to gold and have you ever noticed that a man
who becomes successful tends to continue to become
successful and on the other hand have you noticed
how a man who is a failure tends to continue
to fail it's because of goals some of us have
them some don't people with goals succeed because
they know where they're going now think of a ship
leaving a harbor and think of it with the complete
Voyage mapped out in and plan the captain and crew
know exactly where it's going and how long it
will take it has a definite goal 99,999 times
out of 10,000 it will get to where it started out
to get now let's take another ship just like the
first only let's not put a crew on it or a captain
at the helm let's give it no aiming point no goal
no destination we just start the engines and let
it go I think you'll agree with me that if it gets
out of the harbor at all it will either sink or
wind up on some deserted Beach a derel it can't
go any place because it has no destination and no
guidance it's the same with a human being take the
salesman for example there is no other person in
the world today with the future of a good salesman
selling is the world's highest paid profession if
we're good at it and if we know where we're going
every company needs top-notch salesman and they
reward those men the sky is the limit for them
but how many can you find someone once said the
human race is fixed not to prevent the strong from
winning but to prevent the weak from losing the
American economy today can be likened to a convoy
in time of war the entire economy is slowed down
to protect its weakest link just as the Convoy had
to go at the speed that would permit its slowest
vessel to remain in formation that's why it's so
easy to make a living today it takes no particular
brains or talent to make a living and support a
family today so we have a plateau of so-called
security if that's what a person's looking for
but we do have to decide how high above this
Plateau we want to aim for now let's get back to
The Strangest Secret in the world the story that
I wanted to tell you today why do men with goals
succeed in life and men without them fail well
let me tell you something which if you really
understand it will alter your life immediately
if you understand completely what I'm going to
tell you from this moment on your life will never
be the same again you'll suddenly find that good
luck just seems to be attracted to you the things
you want just seem to fall in line and from now on
you won't have the problems the worries the gwing
lump of anxiety that perhaps you've experienced
before doubt fear well they'll be things of the
past here's the key to success and the key to
failure we become what we think about now let
me say that again we become what we think about
through throughout all history the great wise
men and teachers philosophers and Prophets have
disagreed with one another on many different
things it is only on this one point that they
are in complete and unanimous agreement listen to
what Marcus aelius the great Roman Emperor said
he said a man's life is what his thoughts make
of it Disraeli said this everything comes if a
man will only wait I have brought Myself by long
meditation to the conviction that a human being
with a settled purpose must accomplish it and that
nothing can resist a will that will stake even
existence for its fulfillment Ralph Waldo Emerson
said this a man is what he thinks about all day
long William James said the greatest discovery of
my generation is that human beings can alter their
lives by altering their attitudes of mind and he
also said we need Only In Cold Blood act as if
the thing in question were real and it will become
infallibly Real by growing into such a connection
with our life that it will become real it will
become so knit with habit and emotion that our
interest in it will be those which characterize
belief he also said this if you only care enough
for a result you will almost certainly attain it
if you wish to be rich you will be rich if you
wish to be learned you will be learned if you wish
to be good you will be good only you must then
really wish these things and wish them exclusively
and not wish it the at the same time a hundred
other incompatible things just as strongly in the
Bible you read in Mark 9:23 if thou canst believe
all things are possible to him that believeth Dr
Norman Vincent Peele said this this is one of the
greatest laws in the universe fervently do I wish
I had discovered it as a very young man it dawned
upon me much later in life and I found it to be
one of the greatest if not my greatest discovery
outside of my relationship to God and the Great
Law briefly and simply stated is that if you think
in negative terms you'll get negative results
if you think in positive terms you will achieve
positive results that is the simple fact which is
at the basis of an astonishing law of prosperity
and success in three words believe and succeed
William Shakespeare put it this way our doubts are
traitors and make us lose the good we oft might
win by fearing to attempt George Bernard Shaw said
people are always blaming their circumstances for
what they are I don't believe in circumstances the
people who get on in this world are the people
who get up and look for the circumstances they
want and if they can't find them make them well
it's pretty apparent isn't it and every person
who discovered this for a while believed that he
was the first one to work it out we become what we
think about now it stands to reason that a person
who's thinking about a concrete and worthwhile
goal is going to reach it because that's what he's
thinking about and we become what we think about
conversely the man who has no goal who doesn't
know where he's going and whose thoughts must
therefore be thoughts of confusion and anxiety and
fear and worry becomes what he thinks about his
life becomes one of frustration fear anxiety and
worry and if he thinks about nothing he becomes
nothing now how does it work why do we become what
we think about well I'll tell you how it works as
far as we know now to do this I want to tell you
about a situation that parallels the human mind
suppose a farmer has some land and it's good
fertile land now the land gives the farmer a
choice he may plant in that land whatever he
chooses the land doesn't care it's up to the
farmer to make the decision now remember we're
comparing the human mind with the land because
the mind like the land doesn't care what you plant
in it it will return what you plant but it doesn't
care what you plant now let's say that the farmer
has two seeds in his hand one is a seed of corn
the other is Nightshade a deadly poison he digs
two little holes in the earth and he plants both
seeds one corn the other Nightshade he covers up
the holes Waters and takes care of the land and
what will happen invariably the land will return
what is planted as it's written in the Bible as
ye sow so shall ye reap remember remember the
land doesn't care it will return poison in just
as wonderful abundance as it will corn so up come
the two plants one corn one poison now the human
mind is far more fertile far more incredible and
mysterious than the land but it works the same
way it doesn't care what we plant success failure
a concrete worthwhile goal or confusion misunder
understanding fear anxiety and so on but what we
plant it will return to us you see the mind is
the last great unexplored continent on the earth
it contains riches beyond our wildest dreams it
will return anything we want to plant now you
might say well if that's true why don't people
use their minds more well I think they figured out
an answer to that too our mind comes as standard
equipment at Birth it's free and things that are
given to us for nothing we place little value on
things that we pay money for we value the Paradox
is that exactly the reverse is true everything
that's really worthwhile in life came to us
free our mind our soul our body our hopes our
dreams our Ambitions our intelligence our love
of family and children and friends all these
Priceless possessions are free but the things that
cost us money are actually very cheap and can be
replaced at any time a good man can be completely
wiped out and make another Fortune he can do that
several times even if our home burns down we can
rebuild it but the things we got for nothing we
can never replace the human mind isn't used merely
because we take it for granted familiarity breeds
contempt it can do any kind of job we assign to
it but generally speaking we use it for little
jobs instead of big important ones universities
have proved that most of us are operating on
about 10% of our abilities decide now what is
it you want plant your goal in your mind it's
the most important decision you'll ever make in
your entire life do you want to be an outstanding
salesman a better worker at your particular job
do you want to go places in your company in your
community all you've got to do is plant that seed
in your mind care for it work steadily toward your
goal and it will become a reality it not only
will there's no way that it cannot you see that
is a law like the laws of Sir Isaac Newton the
laws of gravity if you get on top of a building
and jump off you'll always go down you'll never
go up and it's the same with all the other laws
of nature they always work they're inflexible
think about your goal in a relaxed positive way
picture yourself in your mind's eye as having
already achieved this goal see yourself doing
the things you will be doing when you've reached
your goal ours has been called the PHA barbital
age the age of ulcers and nervous breakdowns at a
time when medical research has raised us to a new
plateau of Good Health and Longevity far too many
of us worry ourselves into an early grave trying
to cope with things in our own little personal
ways without learning a few great laws that will
take care of everything for us these things we
bring on ourselves through our habitual way of
thinking every one of us is the sum tootal of
his own thoughts he is where he is because that
is exactly where he really wants to be whether
he'll admit that or not each of us must live off
the fruit of his thoughts in the future because
what you think today and tomorrow next month the
next year will mold your life and determine your
future you're Guided by your mind I remember one
time I was driving through Arizona and I saw one
of those giant Earth moving machines roaring along
the road at about 35 mph with what looked like
20 tons of dirt in it a tremendous incredible
machine and there was a little man perched way up
on top with the wheel in his hands guiding it and
as I drove along I was struck by the similarity of
that machine to the human mind just suppose you're
sitting at the controls of such a vast source of
energy are you going to sit back and fold your
arms and let it run itself into a ditch or are
you going to keep both hands firmly on the wheel
and control and direct this power to a specific
worthwhile purpose it's up to you you're in the
driver's seat you see the very law that gives us
success is a two-edged sword we must control our
thinking the same rule that can lead a man to
a life of success wealth happiness and all the
things he's ever dreamed of for himself and his
family that very very same law can lead him into
the gutter it's all in how he uses it for good or
for bad this is The Strangest Secret in the world
now why do I say it's strange and why do I call it
a secret actually it isn't a secret at all it was
first promulgated by some of the earliest wise
men and it appears again and again throughout
the Bible but very few people have learned it
understand it that's why it's strange and why
for some equally strange reason it virtually
remains a secret I believe that you could go
out and walk down the main street of your town
and ask one man after another what the secret
of success is and you probably wouldn't run into
one man in a month who could tell you now this
information is enormously valuable to us if we
really understand it and apply it it's valuable
to us not only for our own lives but the lives of
those around us our family employees Associates
and Friends life should be an exciting Adventure
it should never be a boore a man should live fully
be alive he should be glad to get out of bed in
the morning he should be doing a job he likes to
do because he does it well one time I heard Grove
Patterson make a speech the editor-in chief of the
Toledo daily blade and as he concluded his speech
he said something that I've never forgotten he
said something like this my years in the newspaper
business have convinced me of several things among
them that people are basically good and that we
came from some place and we're going someplace
so we should make our time here an exciting
Adventure the architect of the universe didn't
Build A Stairway leading nowhere and the greatest
teacher of all the carpenter from The Plains of
Galilee gave us the secret time and time again
as ye believe so shall it be done unto you on
side number one of this record I've explained The
Strangest Secret in the world and how it works now
on this side I want to explain how you can prove
to yourself the enormous returns possible in your
own life by putting this secret to a practical
test I want you to make a test that will last 30
days now it isn't going to be easy if you'll give
it a good try it will completely change your life
for the better back in the 17th century Sir Isaac
Newton the English method mathematician a natural
philosopher gave us some natural laws of physics
which apply as much to human beings as they do to
the movement of bodies in the universe now one
of these laws is that for every action there is
an equal and opposite reaction simply stated
as it applies to you and me it means we can
achieve nothing without paying the price the
results of your 30-day experiment will be in
direct proportion to the effort you put forth to
be a doctor you must pay the price of long years
of difficult study to be successful in selling and
remember that each of us succeeds to the extent of
his ability to sell selling our families on our
ideas selling education in schools selling our
children on the advantages of living the good and
honest life selling our Associates and employees
on The Importance of Being exceptional people
to of course the profession of selling itself
but to be successful in selling our way to the
good life we must be willing to pay the price
now what is that price well it's many things
first it's understanding emotionally as well
as intellectually that we literally become what
we think about that we must control our thoughts
if we're to control Our Lives it's understanding
fully that as you sow so shall you reap secondly
it's cutting away all the Fetters from the mind in
permitting it to soar as it was divinely designed
to do it's the realization that your limitations
are self imposed and that the opportunities for
you today are enormous beyond belief it's
rising above narrow-minded pettiness and
Prejudice thirdly to use all your courage to force
yourself to think positively on your own problem
to set a definite and clearly defined goal for
yourself to let your marvelous mind think about
your goal from all possible angles to let your
imagination speculate freely upon many different
possible solutions to refuse to believe there are
any circumstances sufficiently strong to defeat
you in the accomplishment of your purpose to act
promptly and decisively when your course is clear
and to keep constantly aware of the fact that you
are at this moment standing in the middle of your
own acre of diamonds as Russell Conwell used
to point out fourth save at least 10% of what
you earn it's also remembering that no matter what
your present job it has has enormous possibilities
if you're willing to pay the price now let's just
go over the important points in the price each of
us must pay to achieve the wonderful life that can
be ours it is of course worth any price one you
will become what you think about two remember the
word imagination let your mind soar three courage
concentrate on your goal every day four save 10%
of what you earn and action ideas are worthless
unless we act on them now I'll try to outline
the 30-day test I want you to make now keep
in mind that you have nothing to lose by making
this test and everything you could possibly want
to gain there are two things that may be said of
everyone each of us wants something and each of
us is afraid of something I want you to write on
a card what it is you want more than anything else
it may be more money perhaps you'd like to double
your income or make a specific amount of money
it may be a beautiful home it may be success
at your job it may be a particular position
in life it could be a more harmonious family
each of us want something write down on your
card specifically what it is that you want make
sure it's a single goal and clearly defined you
needn't show it to anyone but carry it with you so
that you can look at it several times a day think
about it in a cheerful relaxed positive way each
morning when you get up and immediately you have
something to work for something to get out of bed
for something to live for look at it every chance
you get during the day and just before going to
bed at night as you look at it remember that you
must become what you think about and since you're
thinking about your goal you realize that soon it
will be yours in fact it's yours really the
moment you write it down and begin to think
about it look at the abundance all around you
as you go about your daily business you have as
much right to this abundance as any other living
creature it's yours for the asking now we come to
the difficult part difficult because it means
the formation of what is probably a brand new
habit and new habits are not easily formed once
formed however it'll follow you for the rest of
your life stop thinking about what it is you
fear each time a fearful or negative thought
comes into your Consciousness replace it with a
mental picture of your positive and worthwhile
goal there will come times when you'll feel like
giving up it's easier for a human being to think
negatively than positively that's why only 5% is
successful you must begin now to place yourself
in that group for 30 days you must take control
of your mind it will think only about what you
permitt it to think each day for this 30-day
test do more than you have to do in addition
to maintaining a cheerful positive outlook give
of yourself more than you've ever done before do
this knowing that your returns in life must be in
direct proportion to what you give the moment you
decide on a goal to work toward you're immediately
a successful person you're then in that rare and
successful category of people who know where
they're going out of every hundred people you
belong to the top five don't concern yourself
too much with how you're going to achieve your
goal leave that completely to a power greater than
yourself all you have to do is know where you're
going the answers will come to you of their own
accord remember these words from The Sermon on the
Mount and remember them well keep them constantly
before you this month of your test ask and it
shall be given you seek and ye shall find knock
and it shall be opened unto you for everyone that
askthe findeth and to him that knock it shall be
opened it's as marvelous and as simple as that
in fact it's so simple that in our seemingly
complicated world it's difficult for an adult
to understand that all he needs is a purpose
and Faith for 30 days do your best if you're
a Salesman go at it as you've never done before
not in hectic fashion but with a calm cheerful
assurance that time well spent will give you
the abundance and return you deserve and want
if you're a homemaker devote your 30-day test to
complete giving of yourself without thinking about
receiving anything in return and you'll be amazed
at the difference it makes in your life no matter
what your job do it as you've never done it before
for 30 days and if you've kept your goal before
you every day you'll wonder and Marvel at this new
life you found Dorothy AB brand outstanding editor
and writer discovered it for herself and tells
about it in her fine book wake up and live her
entire philosophy is reduced to the words act
as though it were impossible to fail she made
her own test with sincerity and faith and her
entire life was changed to one of overwhelming
success now you make your test for 30 full days
don't start your test until you've made up your
mind to stick with it you see by being persistent
you're demonstrating Faith persistence is simply
another word for faith if you didn't didn't have
faith you would never persist if you should fail
during your first 30 days by that I mean suddenly
find yourself overwhelmed by negative thoughts
you've got to start over again from that point
and go 30 more days gradually your new habit
will form until you find yourself one of that
wonderful minority to whom virtually nothing is
impossible don't forget the card it's vitally
important as you begin this new way of living
on one side of the card write your goal whatever
it may be on the other side write the words we've
quoted from The Sermon on the Mount ask and it
shall be given you seek and you shall find knock
and it shall be opened unto you in your spare time
during your test period read books that will help
you inspirational books like the Bible dorothia
Brands wake up and live the magic of Believing
by Claude Bristol and other books that instruct
and Inspire nothing great was ever accomplished
without inspiration see that during these crucial
first 30 days your own inspiration is kept at a
peak above all don't worry worry brings fear and
fear is crippling the only thing that can cause
you to worry during your test is trying to do it
all yourself no know that all you have to do is
hold your goal before you everything else will
take care of itself remember also to keep calm
and cheerful calm and cheerful don't let Petty
things annoy you get you off course now since
making this test is difficult some may say well
why should I bother well look at the alternative
no one wants to be a failure no one really wants
to be a mediocre individual no one wants a life
constantly filled with worry fear and frustration
therefore remember that you must reap that which
you sow if you sow negative thoughts your life
will be filled with negative things if you
sow positive thoughts your life will be cheerful
successful and positive now gradually you'll have
a tendency to for for get what you've heard on
this record play it often keep reminding yourself
of what you must do to form this new habit gather
your whole family about and listen to what's been
said here at regular intervals you know most men
will tell you that they want to make money without
understanding the law the only people who make
money work in the mint the rest of us must earn
money this is what causes those who keep looking
for something for nothing or a free ride to fail
in life the only way to earn money is by providing
people with services or products which are needed
and useful we exchange our product or service
for the other man's money therefore the law is
that our financial return will be in direct
proportion to our service success is not the
result of making money making money is the result
of success and success is in direct proportion to
our service most people have this law backwards
they believe that you're successful if you earn
a lot of money the truth is that you can only earn
money after you're successful it's like the story
of the man who sat in front of the stove and said
to it give me heat and then I'll add the wood how
many men and women do you know or do you suppose
there are today who take the same attitude toward
life there are millions we've got to put the fuel
in before we can expect heat likewise we've got
to be of service first before we can expect
money don't concern yourself with the money
be of service build work Dream create do this and
you'll find there's no limit to the prosperity and
abundance that will come to you Prosperity
is founded upon a law of mutual Exchange
any person who contributes to Prosperity
must prosper in turn himself sometimes the
return will not come from those you serve but
it must come to you from someplace for that is
the law for every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction as you go daily through your
30-day test period remember that your success
will always be measured by the quality and
quantity of service you render and money is a
yard stick for measuring this service no man
can get rich himself unless he enriches others
there are no exceptions to a law you can drive
down any Street in America and from your car
estimate the service that's being rendered
by the people living on that street had you
ever thought of this yard stick before it's
interesting some like ministers and Priests and
other devoted people measure their returns in
the realm of the spiritual but again their
returns are equal to their servs once this
law is fully understood any thinking person
can tell his own fortune if he wants more he
must be of more service to those from whom
he receives his return if he wants less he
has only to reduce this service this is the
price you must pay for what you want if you
believe you can enrich Yourself by deluding
others you can only End by deluding yourself
it may take some time but just as surely as you
breathe you'll get back what you put out don't
ever make the mistake of thinking you can
avert this it's impossible the prisons and
the streets where the lonely walk are filled
with people who tried to make new laws just
for themselves we may avoid the laws of man but
there are greater laws that cannot be broken an
outstanding medical doctor recently pointed out
six steps that will help you realize success one
set yourself a definite goal two quit running
yourself down three stop thinking of all the
reasons why you cannot be successful and instead
think of all the reasons why you can four trace
your attitudes back through your childhood and
try to discover where you first got the idea you
couldn't be a success if that's the way you've
been thinking five change the image you have of
yourself by writing out a description of the
person you would like to be and six act the
part of the successful person you have decided
to become live this new way and the floodgates
of abundance will open and pour over you more
riches than you may have dreamed existed money
yes lots of it but what's more important you'll
have peace you'll be in that wonderful minority
who lead calm cheerful successful lives start
today you have nothing to lose but you have
a life to win this is all Nightingale and thank
you to see the very last time that Jim ran did a
video interview check it out right there next to
me I think love it continue to believe and I'll
see you there Jim ran was one of the fathers
of personal development he was Tony robins's
personal mentor and influenced other greats like
Jack Canfield Mark Victor Hansen and Brian Tracy